sinister - is the sequel to the
surprisingly good movie sinister that
came out a few years ago I really
enjoyed it
a lot of other people did as well and
now we have another one what is going on
with this image I can see it in the
screen what the hell am I in a sinister
tape oh my god okay this is much better
I don't know what that was that was
crazy
sinister - is the sequel to the
surprisingly successful sinister film
that I actually really enjoyed and now
we have another one because that's how
these horror films work they're cheap to
make they can make a whole bunch of them
and maybe they can make money and they
don't really give a clearly because
this one in this film the mother is in
the middle of a custody dispute with her
two children and a husband that she
would really like to divorce who is
abusive and the deputy from the first
film is still investigating the whole
babul thing this creature that haunts
children that gets involved with these
video tapes in some way and these creepy
tapes are made in which people are
killed and someone always finds these
tapes and plays them and they're trying
a lot of ways to bring back elements
from that first film that everyone
thought was very creepy like the tapes
the tapes were by far the creepiest most
disturbing element of the first film in
this film though they're trying to find
an excuse or a reason for why the young
boy in this movie would want to watch
all these tapes every night there really
is no real reason I mean when you really
watch this film and you see this kid
continuously watching these horrific
tapes over and over again they're trying
to make us think that it makes sense in
some way because of this really stupid
plot element that the kid needs to watch
these tapes for a very dumb reason but
in reality it's just hey the first
sinister had creepy tapes so the second
one has to also have creepy tapes
there's no real reason it just needs to
be creepy tapes but the thing that I
thought was very effective about the
first Minister was how psychological it
was it wasn't a very gory film it wasn't
a film that relied on excess it wasn't
like saw or hostile sinister - starts to
go in that direction with increasingly
more elaborate and disturbing tapes that
felt kind of like if you watch the final
destination death scenes except they
were filmed with a crappy camera and
made it look very
be old and cut it together in a creepy
way there's these big traps that are set
up and these things that have to happen
and CGI is implemented now and it's
nowhere near as scary as it was the
first time the other issue is the whole
story is so weak and flimsy it's a scene
to scene setup in which you're waiting
for some sort of loud payoff it's not
filled with false scares like say the
gallows was but there are still tons and
tons of scenes in which but goal is
randomly in a mirror or a computer
screen or in a doorway just standing
there and you begin to wonder what is
this guy actually do does he just stand
around for the audience in the theater
to see and no one else there are some
elements of this film that worked for me
for one I really like the setting the
location I love creepy farms I find
cornfields extremely suspenseful the
main weight of this film's drama comes
with the mother and her custody dispute
with an abusive husband but these
characters are portrayed in such a fake
and over-the-top way they're movie
characters especially the husband and
what I mean by that is you can just tell
this isn't real these guys are acting in
a scene and that's really damaging
however I'm not sure if I pronounce her
name correctly but Shannyn Sossamon or
Sossaman or something along those lines
she's really great as a mother and she's
by far the best thing in this movie I
found the first sinister to be a
suspenseful film that was surprising
that was psychologically disturbing and
very creepy this film story has been
stretched to its full capacity and far
beyond that its tapes are excessively
violent in an unnecessary way to the
point where it almost comes off like a
Saw movie and I haven't even got to the
child performances yet which I really
didn't think were very good and
unfortunately a large portion of this
movies heft relies on those kids being
good and I didn't think they were so I
got a give sinister to a d-plus I think
it's a largely missed opportunity and I
really hope this doesn't become a
franchise in which the gimmick is just
what can we do in the creepy tapes over
and over again now I still got reviews
for hitman agent 47 as well as American
ultra coming I apologize for the
lateness of these reviews as some of you
may know I was in Chicago at Wizard Con
I had a great time there and now I'm
back and I'm going to catch up on all
those reviews thank you so much as
always for watching guys and if you like
this you can click right here
and get Stockman eyes